AS WE JUMP TO
OUR NEXT GAME, LET MY PEOPLE
GROW.
LET MY PEOPLE GROW.
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
>> CHRIS: GOOD NEWS FOR ALL YOU
STONERS WHO LOVE FIDDLER ON
THE ROOF AND BRISKET, AN
ORTHODOX JEWISH ORGANIZATION
HAS BEGUN TALKS TO GET THE
KOSHER SEAL OF APPROVAL ON
MEDICAL MARIJUANA.
MEDICAL MARIJUANA AND JEWISH
PEOPLE SEEM LIKE AN ACTUAL
FIT.
JEWISH PEOPLE HAVE LOTS OF
ANXIETY AND BACK PAIN PLUS
THEY'RE ALWAYS TRYING TO GET TO
YOU EAT SOMETHING.
SO I CAN SAY THAT BECAUSE IT
WAS WRITTEN BY MY JEWISH
WRITER JARED MOSKOWITZ.
HE PROBABLY WANTS MORE MONEY
SINCE HE GOT THAT JOKE ON
THE AIR.
>> AND JEWS LOVE MONEY.
JEWISH. JEWISH, GUYS.
>> CHRIS: #HaimSaban.
>> CHRIS: COMEDIANS --
>> #HighOnSaban.
>> CHRIS: OH, WOW.
A HUNDRED POINTS FOR CLARK
DUKE.
>> I KID, SABAN.
HE DOESN'T LOOK A DAY OVER
DRACULA.
>> CHRIS: COMEDIANS, I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO COME UP WITH AS
MANY KOSHER POT STRAIN NAMES AS
YOU CAN IN 60 SECONDS.
AND BEGIN! KUMAIL.
>> JEWS CONTROL THE DANKS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MIKE.
>> GEFILTE KUSH.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
CLARK.
>> BUDMITZVAH.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MIKE.
>> 420, BUT FOR YOU 419.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. POINTS.
KUMAIL.
>> BONG-JAMIN NETANYAHU.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
I'M GIVING YOU POINTS
BECAUSE YOU SAID IT THAT WAY.
CLARK.
>> GRASSOVER.
>> POINTS.
MIKE.
>> MARIJUANACHEWITZ.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
CLARK.
>> HEY-BRO SCHOOL.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
CLARK.
>> HANUKKUSH.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
KUMAIL.
>> WE WISH TO YOU GROW UP
AND BECOME A DR. FEELGOOD.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT
HANNAKUSH, YOU THOUGHT YOU
ONLY HAD ENOUGH FOR A DAY
BUT IT LASTED EIGHT DAYS,
>> IT'S THE BEST.